this guy is as Minnesota as any human
being could possibly be born in Detroit
Lakes Minnesota went to Minnesota State
University in Mankato now he's a
Minnesota Viking and he led the team in
targets receptions and receiving yards
in a big win to make it seven of their
first nine in the W column in 2017 he's
Adam Thielen here on the Rich Eisen show
how you doing Adam
I'm doing great are you the most
Minnesota person I could possibly know
haha I don't know about that there's a
handful of guys I think that might want
Minnesota but I try to be as much as I
can be I mean like who is there buddy
anybody with as much Minnesota street
cred as you have on your team with
Stephen start on your roster ah maybe
you know Marcus Cheryl's you know he he
went to the University of Minnesota from
Rochester Minnesota and he's been here
longer so I think I think he kind of has
that title okay let's take it away from
him Adam let's let's work on what is it
like for you to be ballin out for for
the Minnesota Vikings well I mean it's
obviously it's awesome to have those
opportunities as a football player as
competitor you love to have the ball in
your hands you love the ball coming your
way but at the same time there's no
better feeling and and at the same time
there's no worse feeling than playing
well and the team not playing well or
the playing well and keep winning so
glad that the team is winning games and
that's what I'm here to do ultimately is
helped us football team win games and
we've been able to do that and I think
we have a lot of you know selfless guys
on this team a lot of guys that are very
unselfish and all we want to do is win
so I was kind of driving at were you a
Vikings fan as a kid I was yeah I grew
up at an early early age my dad is you
know it was a pretty big Vikings fan so
I always wanted to oppose my dad so when
I was really really young I was a real
big Brett Favre fan but you know Stewart
after that I was I was a Vikings fan and
been ever since I was probably five
years old see I mean Adam I didn't want
to call you out I kind of had it walk in
through the front door with that last
question because when I asked you what
is it like balling out for the Vikings
you didn't go oh yeah well I had you
know
I had a Tommy Cramer poster on the wall
or you know or Scott Mitchell on the
wall you know what I mean like I I
didn't hear that one out of you you kind
of went in the present-day seek you
didn't want to talk about your love for
the Packers is what I think right there
was that I just happened I don't know I
don't know if I go that far but I just
had the Triple Threat poster at my room
with Randy Moss Chris Carter Jake Reed
so I definitely had had that poster have
you had any conversations with either of
those triple threats now that you are
one for the Vikings in real life I have
I've been fortunate enough to compete
both Chris Carter Randy Moss and and
both have been really really great for
me and learned a lot from them obviously
watching them play and and now being
able to ask some questions and and you
know it was really cool for me because
as a young player as a young kid they
were the reason why I wanted to play
receiver and play a high level Adam
Thielen here on the Rich Eisen show
fresh after a buck sixty six and eight
catches for the Vikings in it in a big
win in Washington DC right here on the
Rich Eisen show so Case Keenum at
quarterback and there's Teddy
Bridgewater right there walk me through
what is going on with this team in the
quarterback situation for a 7 & 2 team
normally this wouldn't even be a
conversation yes then then definitely an
interesting years as far as that goes
what's obviously starting the season
with salmon and how well of a start he
had of the season and how much
confidence we had in him and then
obviously case coming in and and playing
so well and obviously we have a lot of
confidence of him but he's in the game
and then you know a lot of us on this
team know what Teddy can do you know
we've seen it in the past we've seen it
for the last four or five weeks and
practice and and what he's been able to
do this offseason so it's a good problem
to have we have a lot of guys that can
play at a high level and a lot of guys
that just love the game of football and
want to compete and want to help this
team win games
how does Teddy look in practice he's
been looking great obviously for me I'm
trying to focus on my job and and I'm
usually running routes when
when he's playing so but from the balls
that he's told me he's feeling really
confident and like I said he loves to
play the game and he wants to win it he
wants to compete every day and that's
all you can ask for
and then there's Case Keenum was you're
taking on a Rams team at 7 and 2 and he
used to be the quarterback there is that
oh yeah is that anything that he's even
brought up so far early on this week he
hasn't brought it up but I know it's I
know it's that I know I know he has a
lot of passion for this game and I think
he's you know playing with the chip on
his shoulder this year
from from what happened you know last
year and things like that and where
people think about him and I love that
about him I love that how competitive he
is I love how he prepares every week and
you know really honestly that helps us
as receivers we it pushes us to prepare
better and to bring our best on Sundays
Adam Thielen here on the Rich Eisen show
so you could say is it appropriate to
say I imagine that the entire team's got
a chip on his shoulder because
everybody's waiting to see how the other
shoe drops to maybe the lines do what
they need to do and if Aaron Rodgers was
around no one would give you a shot at
all in this division and yet you're
seven and two Adam I mean do you have a
chip on your shoulder as the entire team
I think so yeah I think we have a lot of
guys miss Tina played a lot of football
and you know have been around here for a
couple of years and and know what kind
of seasons we've had in the past and an
opportunities that may have slipped
through the cracks for us so we have a
lot of guys including coaches that have
our you know complain coming into
Sunday's with a chip on their shoulder
and and I think honestly that's what you
need to win I think that's what you need
to win on Sundays and you need to bring
that every single every single week
what is Mike Zimmer's chip oh man I
think he's got the biggest chip on his
shoulder then than anybody just I think
he's got a lot of people that have
doubted him as whether it be as a
defense coordinator or office or a head
coach I think he's got a lot of doubters
and I think he loves I think he loves
that role proving people wrong that he
can he can coach at a high level and and
you know he can get his players to play
at a high level and that's what that's
what we love about him as players you
know we
bring the the same attitude every day
and you're never gonna get anything fake
from him and get the real deal and
that's bad for ya Dion Sanders speaks so
highly of him so deserving anybody who's
ever played on the team with him or for
him they talk about running through a
brick wall for Mike Zimmer Adam yeah
absolutely I can I can totally relate to
that because like I said he's a guy that
you know sometimes he's tough on us but
you know you know where it's coming from
you know that he does that because he
wants us to win games and that's really
all that matters because winning games
and playing together and keep competing
and he's one of the biggest competitors
out there and like you'd like you said
he'll get his players to run through a
wall for him that's for sure
all right a couple more minutes here
with Adam Thielen on the Rich Eisen show
let's get her some touchdown
celebrations I notice one in London when
I was in honor of Arsenal where you had
taken in a match the day before
true story yes or no it is yeah I was
fortunate enough to get you a sake I was
by one kind of bucket list thing that I
want to do when we are over in London
was get to one of those soccer matches
and and really just experienced that
atmosphere that so many people talk
about and it was it was all it lived up
to be I mean it was it was unbelievable
probably one of the coolest experience
of my life and it was pretty cool that I
could celebrate
in that way in London yeah and then what
do you just slid on your knees you did
one of those things right I mean you
could have technically just run around
like crazy right I mean they normally
that's what these footballers do take
off their shirt run around like crazy
you could have done that that's true if
my jersey wasn't so hard to take off I
probably would have ripped it off but it
takes me about 20 minutes to get on and
off before and after so I'm not even
attempt that and where did the game of
Landover Maryland leapfrog come in from
this past day you know you know I think
it was kind of very similar to the duck
duck create a car most people safe duck
duck goose but you know it's kind of
similar to that you know we talked about
in the huddle before the play and say
hey if we score on this Drive let's
let's do it everybody kind of get in a
line and and let's do it but I was a
little worried when I went on the ground
and look
we're to follow the only guy to do that
is commitment Adam somebody's always got
to be first in the game of leapfrog you
know so you talk about it in the huddle
that's confidence right there Adam well
the cool you know obviously in the NFL
we have all these you know TV timeouts
and all that so you get a lot of time in
the huddle that we're all just kind of
looking at each other so it's a good
time to just go ahead we score this
drive you know we're getting in the red
zone and say if we score that's let's do
it just to have some fun and and it's a
good chance for us to just keep it keep
it light in the huddle you know you
don't need to be all stressed out and
all worried about scorner this and that
it's like I said it's a good chance to
just keep it light keep everybody just
having fun and last one for you Adam
anybody openly talking about the fact of
where the Superbowl is taking place this
year anybody just throwing it out there
let's stay home the rest of the year no
I don't think anybody in our locker room
has said anything about it just because
we have so much work to do and this
league is it's a very tough tough lead
to win it doesn't matter the team's
record you're planning and so them here
matter where you're playing it it's
tough to win this league so we gotta
keep taking it one game at a time and
you can keep taking care of business I
gotta tell you I reject that notion Adam
come on now you'd be the first why don't
you be the first walk in that locker
room and say come on everybody at my
house party coming up on the Monday
after do it what do you think what we've
been doing you know honestly I think
that's kind of what's helped me get to
where I came to is just taking it one
day at a time I think when you look too
far ahead on things you just you lose
focus on the little things and you kind
of get out of character so like I said
we're gonna just stick to what's got us
here and we're gonna keep doing that all
right regardless Adam regardless whether
you make it or not would you take me ice
fishing that week I would love to
that'd be great I've never I've never
done it never but for you but for you we
can't have like you know the warm cozy
house and all that we got we got to do
like the real deal sit on a bucket you
know out on the ice and no no
Theater none of that what I'm come on
sir it so I'd have to be out there on a
bucket with nothing just a real
experience why is that a real experience
there's no there's no other way to do it
you know there's no I mean there's
definitely there's any better way to do
it and and I've got go I personally I
won't go as vision without eyes house
but Minnesota okay
well let's do that let's stay in touch
and Super Bowl week on there all week
maybe after one of my shows if you're
free I hope you're not but if you're
free let's do it yeah we'll make it
we'll make it work regardless okay even
if we're in the game I got obviously I
got some time to take you out I like it
Adam Thielen Congrats on on a great
start to the season and we will chat
down the road you got it at ceiling 19
on Twitter from the Minnesota Vikings
Adam Thielen the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience